so the brain is a marvelous organs my
favorite organ and it's very sensitive
to the environment so for a moment to
moment our brains are bombarded by
stimuli from our senses and whether I'm
looking at a computer screen or reading
a book or having a conversation the
information comes in my ears in my eyes
it's translated into little neural
chemical packets that are transmitted
across little synapses or connection
sites between the brain cells or neurons
and all the information is understood is
compartmentalize and process and it's a
quite a remarkable thing that our brain
is doing now one thing that's quite
interesting is that if the brain spends
a lot of time with the specific mental
task over and over again the neural
circuits that control that task will
strengthen it'll actually grows synapses
if we neglect certain tasks the neural
circuits that control those tasks will
weaken and I think this is an issue
we're facing right now because young
people the digital natives are spending
so much time with their technology that
their technological circuits are great
they can use this technology communicate
to their friends from moment they can
use this technology communicate with
their friends from moment to moment
search online is marvelous what they can
do but they're not spending enough time
talking to each other face-to-face so
having eye contact recognizing nonverbal
cues the neural circuits controlling
those mental tasks I'm concerned that
they are weakened
there was a recent study that involved
about 200 young people ages 17 to 23 and
the task involved watching a face morph
from a neutral expression to either an
angry expression or to a happy face and
they found that when these young people
played a violent video game before the
face recognition task it had a
significant effect on their ability to
recognize the emotional expression from
the face now that's some systematic
scientifically but many parents will
notice in their kids if they play too
many video games if they spend too much
time with their technology that they're
not looking at them in the arm that they
become irritable that there are
personality changes and I think this is
a whole area that is just beginning to
emerge as an area of study
no one's directly study the brain
effects of text messaging but it's an
interesting phenomena in sure it's it's
increasing some neural circuits
diminishing others it has an interesting
effect on people and in fact young
people use it so much that i found that
college educators professors are having
trouble getting the kids to stop texting
during class we even take five minute
text breaks halfway through the class
you know it's just it's inconceivable
for me that they're doing this but
they're doing it now it's an it's an
interesting phenomenon how it's
affecting the way we think in the way
were you late I think they're there may
be issues with creativity thinking
outside the box I mean everybody is so
connected we're like a colony of ants or
bees checking ideas from moment to
moment and not stopping to spend time
and ponder faults in fact we have a
staccato quality to our thinking it's
just like we're jumping from thought to
thought as we do we're jumping from
thought to thought just the way we jump
from website to website so there's a
sacrifice of depth of thinking for
breath of thinking we say this there's
an upside and that is that the brain is
malleable at any age we found that in
our older volunteers and we know that in
young people as well so we can
understand what we're doing to our
brains and we can change our behavior
and our brains will repair themselves
will come back pretty quickly
well just as we found with our brain on
Google study that we could significantly
activate neural circuits in just a week
we can change people's behaviors which
will alter their brain neural circuitry
so it's the same principle is how much
time you spend on the task how that will
determine those neural circuits most of
these changes are not permanent
certainly very early in development
there can be permanent damage if there's
deprivation or other kinds of insults to
the brain but most of the time we can't
change it the problem is if these are
long-term habits people are often very
resistant to change especially if
they're addicted to a technology it's
it's very hard to give up smoking and
it's very hard for some people to give
up their technology